Hi again, Robert.
Hola.
How are you?
Good.
See here, I think I'm trying to join a second time. See me.
See here, I think I'm trying to join a second time. You see me?
Yes.
I don't. Can't see it yet.
It says, Robert, someone is waiting.
It says, Robert, someone is waiting. Try to try again.
By the track.
And you have a bit of an echo, not sure why.
Shouldn't be there anymore.
Yeah, perfect. Better.
No.
Give me one second.
Alright, the echo should be gone.
Yep, better.
And you should be able to see my smiling face.
I can see your smiling face.
Let me blur my background so you don't see the lazy dog in the background.
Yeah.
That's my assistant, he's useless.
I have like 3 dogs.
Oh my gosh, God bless you. You must not have any children.
Okay.
No, I don't.
Right.
It's either that or the other, right?
Correct.
Yes, yes, my kids begged me. We got this dog six years ago. They begged me for the dog. Now they're in college.
Yeah.
He's my dog; I didn't want him, but I love him.
I have three, I have nine years old, I have one year old.
Nine.
Yes, and then I have like 3 months old.
Oh my goodness. So you got your hands full.
Yes, exactly. But, you know, after a stressful day at work, you go home, you see them better. That's good.
I come home and got to walk them. I got to feed them. I don't want to serve anybody. I serve people all day long.
Yeah.
It.
Again, I love him.
They're, yeah, they're an exemption, you know. All right, I know that you are seeing a whole new face on this call, not me, thank God.
Yeah.
I always see new faces on this call. I must be popular.
We want to make sure that you know everybody and just wanted to let you know that I know that Rodge hasn't been here for quite some time. He's with ITBD still, all right? So he hasn't left us, thank God. But...
Moved on to bigger and better.
Yes, moving on to a bigger and better role for the entire organization. So I wanted to bid you farewell, probably not a farewell, just see you again. And I'm introducing you to Marky. So Marky would be the one taking over the role of Rodge for the co-manage, which is also working directly
Good.
with Lawrence. So Marky, I wouldn't steal his thunder. I would let him introduce himself. Go ahead.
Hi, Robert. Good day. Nice to meet ya. Um, yeah, you can call me, yeah.
Hey, Mark, hey, Mark, I hope.
I'm gonna try to call you Marky. I feel a certain way about calling a grown man Marky.
Kip.
Ha ha ha!
Are you talking about the marky mark?
But, but that's my issue, not yours. Nice to meet you, Marky.
Okay, so yeah, thanks. Yeah, I just want to give some information about me. So yeah, I've been, or I have 12 year experience in the MSP background, the industry, basically. And my previous job is from First Focus. It's an MSP company as well, which is based in Australia.
I've been working there for about four years and I'm managing their After Hours team. And it consists of 18 support staff members across Manila, Australia, India, Ireland, and South Africa. So aside from being the team lead for the After Hours team, I'm also doing the incident manager role for them.
during weekends, which is responsible for P0 and P1 tickets. Basically, it's an outage tickets. I'm the one who's catering the bridge calls from the support side and also at the client side. So every 15 minutes, I'm responsible on updating the clients and what's happening and what's the next step.
Yep.
for the outage that they're experiencing. And not only that, I'm also doing the dispatch coordinator role for the After Hours team, which is assigning tickets to the team and making sure that all VIP tickets that has been raised during that day has been handled on a timely manner. So.
Yeah, looking forward to work with you, Robert.
Thank you.
Good. Sounds like you got a lot of jobs like me.
Yeah.
PH.
One-stop shop. All right. Okay.
Yeah.
I don't want to be that anymore. I want one job. It's not working. Every time somebody leaves, I get their job.
Ha ha.
That's a scam, Robert. I gotcha. All right, so I'm sharing the screen. So moving forward, I'm doing it today, but moving forward with our monthly business review and service review, we're going to do, Marky would be the one who will be presenting it.
Yeah.
So I'll still be here. I won't be leaving. I'll still be attending this call. But yeah, mainly this will be the show of Marky and Lawrence. Okay? All right.
Is this?
Good.
Okay, first slide, that's not, this is not us.
Perfect.
Yeah, alright, yes.
You know that, right?
That's not us. That's not our company. That's not our logo. That's not us. So this is a rebranding call, apparently. I'm just joking.
It's a different, yeah, it's a different logo.
Different logo.
Yeah.
Apologies for that. It was, we created this and we, apparently it's not, it can be just AI all the time. You have to use human touch.
Alright, that's fine.
Yeah, yeah, so amazing.
So amazing. Changed my life. Go ahead.
All right.
True.
PH.
For the agenda, we have check-in, highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, way forward, and our recap.
All right, so check in, how are things at the moment? I heard that Lawrence is doing alerts now again for Avik. How was that? How was it going?
Going good. He's our subject matter expert, right? And I think we had to accept that. That's with Auvik, our network monitoring tool. And I think we assigned it to somebody else and they kind of dropped the ball and things were falling apart. So we've passed that back to Lawrence just to get it right. So he's going through all the customers, making sure all the alerting is set up correctly.
Yeah.
Mhm.
This one, mhm.
Ohh.
Okay.
Yeah, we just kind of neglected it. As I said, you know, we have a, we had a few people leave. So we're just kind of recalibrating and reassigning things. In addition, we changed how we measure utilization.
Mhm.
So if you got your pen and paper available. Full transparency, I'm totally against it.
Mm.
Yeah, go ahead.
I've been doing this for, I've been in IT 35 years, 30 something years. But typically what we measure, and I believe what you guys measure is productivity.
Out.
Right, so that's how much time you're spending working.
For some reason.
Yes.
And I wasn't in that argument; they didn't invite me.
We are only measuring billable time.
As utilization.
And I don't know if you guys have a way of categorizing that based on what Lawrence sends you. But we may have to probably talk about that so you can understand where we're coming from as far as utilization is concerned.
Yeah.
Yep, I gotcha.
Yeah, the caveat there is, you know, I believe we used to have a dispatcher. We don't have a dispatcher anymore. So our techs are doing the triage, the dispatching and running through the tickets. This is not billable time. This is not billable time.
And.
Um...
Are going to hire any service coordinators soon?
No.
Okay.
It's a whole different meeting.
You know how it is. It's, you know, from a high level CEO executive perspective, you know, they look at
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
A person leaving.
I guess it's your fault then.
Oh.
And I do say that, right? I say I feel like I'm being penalized for being a high performer.
Yeah.
right? Because if I drop the ball on everything, they would take things away from me. So now I'm stuck because there's no pain, right, when somebody leaves because it's already being filled. But we have our techs doing it. Unfortunately, that's not billable time.
Mhm.
So obviously Lawrence's utilization is going to look a little bit lower because he's not getting on our end, he's not getting credit for the time he's actually working.
Okay.
Hopefully soon that'll change, but I don't think you guys need to change what you're doing. For me, from a performance perspective, I'm going to look at productive time.
Hello!
Bye.
Mhm.
But from an internal reporting perspective, instead of him being in the hundreds, he's probably going to be more in the 80s. But obviously that's not a reflection on him because I believe in giving, I see a ticket as three things.
Perspective, yeah.
So 30 years. Yeah.
Right? You triage the ticket, you work the ticket, you close the ticket. So it doesn't make any sense to me why you're only measuring 2 out of three when they wouldn't exist unless you did step one.
Mhm.
That's cool.
Right. You guys are nodding. They're not.
Well...
Because what if we stop, what if we stop altogether doing unbillable work and only work tickets? There'd be no tickets to work because they're all in triage. But I'm going to whine and cry. I'm going to whine and cry. But again, I think I'm fine with you all.
Mhm.
I get that.
measuring the way you do, because that's the way the industry does it. But again, just we're coming from a different perspective. So again, where you where you're seeing him in the hundreds, again, I think about probably 10 to 15% of his time is doing dispatch. The good thing is, is one of the reasons I gave him Avik and I'm going to start giving him more escalations so he can have more billable time.
I hear him.
Mhm.
Um...
So his numbers are up. But we'll see. But, you know, from a performance perspective, you know, that's the only thing that's changed for us. But, you know, Lawrence is doing this thing. Nobody says anything. Thank you, Marky. Let me put you on the phone with my CEO.
Gotcha.
Mhm.
Yeah, I agree, Robin. Yeah, because usually if you, if you're triaging a ticket, so basically if you're triaging a ticket, so it'll take time as well, categorizing the ticket and whatsoever, yeah, before you action the ticket. So basically, yeah.
All right.
Really, if you think I can take this.
Yeah.
Basically, if you're triaging a big kid, so. Gregg.
It takes time.
It takes time. 100%. And we had a dispatcher, right? So the company has already justified.
Forty or so hours a week to that, but they don't want to give the the the the the time is ghost time.
Yeah.
But I understand, they look at different numbers from a different perspective. The problem is, is it looks like my team isn't working, and that's what I don't like.
That should stop.
How are you capturing this unbillable utilization? Do you have like an admin ticket to track it? Yeah, it's not billable, but at least there are hours spent there and you can actually put in things that you've done, like triage, this, that. Again, it's not going to matter. It's not going to
Yeah.
be taken under my billable utilization, but then if you're in a report, it's still there, there's a ticket and you have hours spent. And can you actually understand like, okay, I did triage, I did dispatch, I did this, that, whatever.
Yeah, as long as...
Correct.
Yeah, so...
Yep, so once a day, each tech has a ticket for dispatch and triage, right? And that's where they're putting their time. Unfortunately, that ticket is being billed to internal, right? It's an Omega Court ticket.
Mhm.
Yes. Yep.
So what I've told him is if, you know, sometimes triaging is difficult because you have no idea what the person is talking about. You may have to do their research or whatever. So the protocols, if it's more than 10 minutes, bill it to the customer.
Okay.
So again, we're going to work through that. I just had the conversation and I showed them the play on how to run this last week. So again, I'm working with them to figure it out, but I just never been anywhere where it's only billable time.
Gotcha.
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
Vaid.
right? It should be productive time, right? So theoretically, it should be anything that's not lunch, not a break, or not admin time, like training. That stuff is not billable, but still productive. Because the company still wins, right?
Yeah.
Yes.
Mhm.
But here's what go ahead.
Yeah, it's still yours, right? Yeah, exactly. So what we're going to do moving forward, I know that we are actually capturing billable, but Mark and I just talked, which is very timely because you've opened this up, that they asked him, can you also...
You're working. You're working.
gauge the non-billable time so that we can actually see the percentage of it and what he does. And then we can report that to you on a monthly basis. And we actually know what he does on his other 20% half of the time, right? We know that he's working. It's just a matter of understanding what those 20% consist of.
Yeah.
Yes.
Correct. Yeah, the majority of that's going to be...
It's the dispatch time, right? It's going to be mostly dispatch and training. What we're going to try to do is this network monitoring stuff is he can put that time in a ticket. So like if he's working on.
Judge dispatch, yes, exactly.
But...
the monitoring services for a customer.
Mhm.
that he should be able to put that towards the customer. So hopefully this extra Avic stuff is not going to affect his utilization. It's going to be more of that dispatch ticket and training. That's going to be the unbillable stuff for most of them.
Kour.
Gotcha. We'll be looking at that soon. And then next monthly business review, we're going to show that data for you. Okay. Great. Thank you so much. All righty.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, that's perfect.
Okay, so highlights. So again, just like we talked about, new assigned tasks, network monitoring system, Mohit. I missed that, by the way. I've been getting that in past. It's been reassigned to Lawrence for daily checks and troubleshooting. So Lawrence is checking the system and creating tickets for sync issues. That's what he told us. So to be honest with you, it's a
Yep.
good thing because you're not just, you know, working on a daily Helpdesk issue. You're actually getting an experience back again with the network, which is very, very nice also for him. Yeah, so next is it.
Yeah.
Most definitely.
And again, I'm also giving him all my escalations. I don't know if I've talked to him about that. So a lot of time.
Is he an escalation personnel? Is he like a, I don't know.
Is an escalation point?
Unofficially, I would say. For some context, again, we lost a senior engineer. We lost two senior engineers.
OK.
Mhm.
Typically, a lot of the escalations come to me.
And because I wear a bunch of hats, I work them. But what I want is for Lawrence to have that first touch. And if he needs to pull me in, he gets to pull me in.
Mhm.
Gotcha.
So yeah, I don't know if that's a role change that might be up for further discussion when we start talking about his money one day. But
Do you want to do an, I don't know, maybe have that as his rock? I don't know. Do you, and to train him as a senior engineer and maybe down the line we can talk about that role.
Yeah, 100%. I think that's where he needs to be going. Obviously, we need to figure out what that path looks like. I know we've talked about, you know, at Omega Core, if you get a certification, you've proven that you're smart. I personally don't believe that this certifications mean you're smart. That just mean you can take tests. But at Omega Core, in order to get leverage,
Mhm.
Mhm. Mhm.
Are you are you able to?
you know, a certification is always strongly suggested. And I'm not sure what we had him looking at. I think it might have been Azure, the first level Azure. Yeah, I think that's what we talked about. I'm not, I don't remember though.
Mhm.
AZ 900.
Okay.
Yeah, Marky and I can circle back with Lawrence so that we can get that sorted for him, because just like what I mentioned, I think when even when Rodge was here, because he's so productive at work, he doesn't have time to actually do something else, right? And we have, that's the reason why we have CDP in place is because we wanted them to grow also, but we wanted to grow.
A
Yes.
Yep.
with them, with you guys. So if we have that, if we could put that senior engineer as his rock, then we can probably add one of his milestone to get that rock and to achieve that rock would be getting that AZ900 and work with you for that training.
Yeah.
Yep. Yeah, so I don't know if you have any context surrounding it. I know. What I don't know is if...
I don't know how much certification is.
Test costs.
I don't think it's that much for AZ900.
Right, but.
Really?
Sounds good.
Yeah, I have a couple of engineers that has taken it.
Let's see. Oh, it's $99.
Yeah, not bad.
99 America. Oh, that's fine. Okay. Yeah, what I didn't want was, you know, the price to be a roadblock, you know what I'm saying? But yeah, I figured it was like 5 or $600. I haven't taken a certification exam in 20 years.
Okay.
Yes.
What we do here in ITBD is that you don't pay anything just yet. You only pay once the engineer has successfully passed it, and then we can reimburse them. So initially, so engineer usually pays for it initially. It's like a handshake, you know? You wanted something, it will help the partner, it's a handshake. I'll pay for it for the time being.
Love it, good.
Yeah.
Once they pass, then we're going to talk to the partner about it, for the money.
Mmh.
Mhm.
I don't know what the value of $99 in the Philippines is. Does that make sense?
Not bad. It's not bad. Yes. Yeah, I know. I get it. That's true.
Right. I don't know what your standard rent is, right? I don't know what a week's worth of groceries costs, you know, as compared to the dollar. So yeah, if y'all are covering it, money's not a problem then. Lawrence can do all he wants.
Mhm.
So what we do is we talk to him about it. If he's willing to pay, then he pays. Then after he pays, then we'll let you know if he did pass or not. And are you guys okay with Accounting invoicing you with that? And then we are reimbursed for the 99 bucks.
Good.
Okay, perfect. All right, well, yeah, let's get it started.
Okay.
and have the conversation with him again. I think he's aligned.
Yeah, let's whatever we need to do to get that, let's get it.
Oh.
Sure, okay, we'll get that sorted out. All right, next is Lauren's has demonstrated reliability and commitment. I think he only have one PDO this month for the past April and no attendance issues with no coverage gaps.
No. We just, we miss him so much when he's not here. You know, some people have that kind of impact, right? Some people miss days and it's business as usual. Like, oh, you weren't here yesterday? Yeah, we didn't know. But Lawrence, man, we feel it. We feel it, man. We feel it. But yes, yeah, I'm fine.
Yeah.
Mhm.
True. Were they out?
Oh, I didn't know.
Okay, it's a good problem.
I am, you know, family first, take care of yourself, all that stuff. So I'm not worried about when people take days off.
Gotcha. All right, perfect. Let's move on to performance. So as you can see, the utility rate is within our average billable utilization goal, which is 80%. So he's not below that. He's getting 1% above it.
Good.
But again, we wanted to make sure it's consistent. And then sooner after this, moving forward with the deck, we're going to have an unbillable also so that we understand what's the non-billable utilization is all about and what it consists of. Okay.
Yeah.
Yep, got you. Thank you. Give me one second. My manager, give me one second. This dude keeps pinging me.
Right.
Next.
Sure.
PH.
My manager's awesome. Yeah, but I pinged him two hours ago and then he's paying me here.
Of course they do.
They do that a lot. They just respond once.
And now he's paying me 7, he's not, and he's riding me now.
Story over life.
What's wrong with this guy, man? Whoops. All right, we're good. I blocked, I put, I did this to him. Dude, chill.
All right.
Okay, back to you guys.
All right, so I just wanted to work with or show you the goal for our ticket close for today. It's a ticket standard. So as you can see, total ticket work and ticket close is not that far. So those are the things that we also make sure that we keep an eye on is the resolution. So
it doesn't have like a carryover from that week to another week to another week. And then there will be a lot of backlog tickets. So that I think would benefit us in reporting that soon. So if you have like 7 tickets that you worked on and you close 15, it's still good. It's 88% resolution time. And the rest.
80%, 95%, 95, 96 resolution rate. That means that he's just completing, if not all, most of it on that same day, which is also first resolution as well, which is a good job.
Yeah.
Yeah, continuous improvement. I think what we can do also, you can try to check the carryover from that week until the end of the month, so we can see if there's any backlog. But showing the tickets work versus ticket closed, it actually shows us that picture already.
Okay. Yeah, we have some clients who just aren't responsive. It's like one minute the house is on fire, then we don't hear from them for two weeks. It's like, what are you doing? What are you supposed to do with that? But yeah, I get it. I understand.
Yeah.
Yeah, any.
Gotcha. And for sometimes a partner or a client to send an email, it's urgent. No one sends an email if it's an urgent matter. You call them. So, right? You don't call, you don't send an email to the fire station and say, oh, my husband on fire. So that's that. Just fine.
Yeah.
I'm going to use that. I'm going to put it in quotes when I do it because that's yours. Right. If it's a real fire, why the heck are you emailing us? You know what I'm saying? Makes sense.
POV.
Yeah.
Exactly. Exactly. But yeah, overall, he's been doing good. We just wanted to make sure that, you know, we're always, he's always consistent with the work that he's done and with the quality of it, which we're very proud of. So.
Me too.
All right, way forward. So we have upcoming ITBD holiday. It's Memorial Day on your side of the fence also. You guys are off this day, right? And he can take that off as well. Okay. All right. So Marky, make sure that you add that to the list that Lauren's will be out on the 25th as well.
No.
We are closed, yes. Yes, he can.
Yep.
Next utilization, other tasks, and extra work that can be handed over so that their time can be utilized. So what we're going to do, again, we're going to catch the non-billable. We're going to work with Lawrence about his current rock and what's going to be the milestone for that. And then I'll probably just give you an idea on when
Is he going to, when are we going to talk about the annual appraisal also so that you guys are aware? Okay.
That works.
All right, I think that is eating much it. Last, build it live. I think, yeah, I talked to you about this. We're able to.
Register.
I don't, I'm not coming.
Yeah.
Blake.
Okay, anybody from...
For a number of reasons.
But I think somebody is. I think somebody is. Yeah.
Do you have plans? Okay.
Have they registered?
I don't want.
I think Andy will be there.
Yeah, that's that's that's big boy stuff.
I know Andy can't wait. I know Andy can't wait to be there. Here's my thing, right? Here's my thing. I love my job. But after work, I want to leave. I don't want to have dinner with you. I don't want to party with you.
It will be.
Not true.
Yeah.
Good.
Mhm.
Sorry, Robert, I...
I don't want to spend all day with you and then I don't want to do that.
Yes.
Just want to go and have fun, right? Yeah, it's a...
Yeah.
I just wanna go and then leave, leave them.
It's it's fun. It's it. Well, it is fun. However, you know the amount of work that you're gonna leave behind is gonna pile up as well. We do have that.
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly. But I think some, I, we typically have our CEO and our operations manager go to these things.
Gotcha. Can you confirm? You think you can confirm that?
But, yeah, yeah.
Let me, let me ping, let me ping this dude.
And I'm 100% sure he's not going to answer now, but...
Ohh.
But yeah, just in case you guys have confirmation, if they can join, just let me know.
Yeah, yeah, I pinged them. Yeah, I pinged them. Yeah, you might, yeah. I'll let you know so you can find them and meet them.
Sure. Oh, by the way.
I know we went to the one, I went a couple years ago. It was fine, but...
The food was good, the candy station was amazing.
And they had a McLaren. I remember the McLaren. There was a McLaren in the showroom. That was amazing. But other than that, I don't, you know.
S.
All you remember was the Kenny.
Yeah.
PH.
Wow, fancy.
Gotcha. They're going to talk about AI most of the time at the latter part of this program because, you know, it's everywhere. I wanted to be helping out our partners with AI and having to start with it is actually sometimes the problem and we're stuck with how to begin.
Of course.
Yeah.
So that's where we're gonna help out with the partners that's gonna attend. So I think it's gonna be.
Yep.
Of course, and anywhere you go, if you're not talking about AI, you're doing the wrong thing.
Yes, exactly, because it's just, it's just there, you know, you can hide.
Right.
It's here. It's here. And it reminds me of when the internet started and all that good stuff. You know, you got to figure out how you how to use it. You know what I'm saying? All that stuff. Yeah. And again, I'm older than I look. So I was there.
Exactly.
Mobile phones. Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
Okay.
You guys are young. I was there.
Yeah.
Fun, OK.
So, we'll figure it out.
Can you also...
So, he, he, he hasn't responded, so I'll let you guys know; I'll let you know if he responds.
Sure.
Gotcha. Can you hear this? I'm not sure I'm here just yet at that time. Were are we not able to whitelist each other on Teams so that we can talk on MS Teams? Can we do that? Because I know that you don't have like a group chat unlike any other partners before or that we currently have every time that it got a...
Talk to you, I gotta message you or send you an email. So, is there any reason why we don't have that white listing for instance?
I'm assuming what you mean is direct teams to each other.
Yes, yeah.
I don't, this is the first time this conversation has ever happened, right? We didn't, we didn't see there was a need for it, right? No one said we need, no one said we needed it.
Ooh.
Mm.
Okay, I thought there was some security issues in the past, that's why we didn't allow it, but I wasn't here, so I didn't want to assume anything. But can we revisit that conversation and maybe we can do that?
Yeah, yeah, that's no problem.
I think it would be easier for us to communicate.
That's so sweet. Now, you know I get a lot of Teams messages too, so I'll probably have the same response as email. It won't be personal. But yeah, we can revisit that. Yeah, so I think there needs to be...
This.
But I can mention you every time.
Yeah.
some kind of tenant to tenant agreement or something, so we can talk to each other.
I can, I have it, and yeah, I can send you that email. We can, you can follow after for how to whitelist it, so we can actually.
Yes, send it to me. I'll get somebody. I'm not going to do it. Oh, look, I probably will. But yeah, I'll present it to the team and, you know, let people smarter to be making some decisions. But yeah, send me what you got and we'll go from there.
Okay.
Sure.
Okay, perfect. We can do that. Thank you so much.
You're welcome.
All right, again, this is Team GPS. You know this already. If you wanted a demo, you let me know. We can schedule that forward. But yeah, I think that is pretty much it. Do you have anything else you wanted to talk about?
No, we're good. You know, I'm happy-go-lucky. Lawrence is killing it. You guys are awesome. Yeah, we're good.
Mhm.
Okay, perfect. So yeah, thank you very much again. Happy that you and Marky have met and moving forward, you'll be seeing him more on this calls. Okay.
Thank you.
Yeah.
All good. Nice to meet you, Marky. Always a pleasure, Andy.
Nice to meet you.
Always. Thank you very much. Have a good day. Bye.
Thank you.
All right, have a good one. Bye.
Take care, bye bye.